human beings are trying very very hard
to be
monogamous when they're not
designed for a very long period of time
millions of years to be
monogamous um monogamy as it's defined
in the thanks Steph monogamy as it's
defined in the animal kingdom is
essentially mating for Life uh I did a
quick Google search before we started
this that includes wolves coyotes
Gibbons swans sandill Cran dick dicks
whatever the hell that is seahorses bald
eagles Prairie voles beavers albatrosses
barnow termites Scarlet Maca I could
keep going there's a lot of animals out
there it seems really common in the um
uh bird Community bird Community Birds
you know for Birds uh avens the um the
reason for it seems to be is because you
got to sit on the eggs keep them warm so
while one is off collecting insects or
whatever it is they happen to eat for
bald eagles it's fish or whatever uh the
other one sits on the eggs and um they
kind of take take turns doing that so
it's by necessity when it comes to
rearing children and I think that sexual
strategies for human beings are very
interesting they're very very very
interesting like if you get like if you
really want to see how interesting human
beings
are do some research on evos pych on
mating strategies between men and women
I've read all the books I've read tons
of studies I talked about some of the
stuff in one of the chapters of my book
and the TLD drr version of it is is that
we suck at monog monogamy we're not
monog monogamous in the definition that
the animal kingdom uses meaning they
mate for life
um their partner dies an albatross dies
at Sea a shark gets it or something like
that uh that's it you know they don't go
and find another mid it's not like they
start dating and download Tinder and
swiping or something like that and
they'll go and find another Albatross
that's it they're done they are widowed
for for Life uh that's really what the
definition is Right human beings like to
call ourselves monogamous but we're
really not I think Esra Perell defined
it the best when she said that we're
more monogamish you know uh where for
women it's like you know they prioritize
see women's sexual strategy is best
defined as prioritizing the best that
they can get that's what hypergamy is is
this the best that I can get the problem
is that that usually means because
they're always asking themselves that
question subc consciously somewhere it's
the best that I can get guy may start to
decline she may increase something may
happen he widowed whatever it happens to
be she'll just move on women move on
we've seen it whether she cheats on you
whether she dumps you whether she cheats
and dumps you um women move on usually
to bigger and better things bigger and
better guys um
the woman that you're dating right now
if she's fully committed to you and
other guys are invisible and you're her
hypergamous best option other guys are
mostly invisible to her and any guy from
her past looks like a loser compared to
you that's that's why you guys are pair
bond in that sense that's why she's got
a strong connection to you that's why
she wants to be with you and continues
to choose you sort of thing so you
understand that
but Esther Perell calls it managa managa
Mish sort of speak meaning
kind of like one person at a time that's
how women choose basically men on the
other hand prioritize differently so I'm
going to be talking a lot about the
differences between men and women on
this one because there's vast amounts of
them and the and the other interesting
thing too is women's
solipsism just got to write it down
forgot to put a note down for it can't
see the male perspective they just can't
and I'll explain that in a little bit
too so Esther Perell wrote a bunch of
books uh meeting in captivity is
probably most prolific one dealing with
the subject um I want to be clear I'm
not endorsing condoning or uh you know
any of those things when it comes to uh
stepping out on a relationship you do
you you do whatever you want I don't
give a [__] um it's good it's bad
whatever you know it's all it's it's
it's happened to all of us at some point
like if you've been around it's
happening you at some point I'm trying
to think right now I've one
two three probably I'm going to say
three times
that I'm aware of chicks have like
stepped out on me um I'll share a story
of a close friend uh to sort of set the
tone and get this thing moving along
here um dude is dating this lady uh
after he got divorced um he's got kids
she's got kids they do the whole blended
family [__] thing that you know
women like to sell guys and um they are
on a vacation and the kids are
misbehaving on the vacation um kids are
basically becoming brats very entitled
as they have done in the past as he's
ignored in the past and he decides to
send them off from the vacation uh spot
that he rented sending them
home um basically had enough not
expecting more than just checking her
right um meaning your kids are behaving
badly they're acting like Bratz you're
not willing to deal with them so I'm
going to send you off you can all go now
uh and I'll hang out here with my kids
and finish my vacation and expecting her
to sort of like check herself and come
in line and behave better and recognize
that uh he's not going to put up with
the [__] but that's not what
happened what ended up happening was she
got rid of the kids uh over to Dad and
she went out with a friend and uh met a
couple of guys you know two of them and
she ends up spending the night with the
dude banging them all night morning
night whatever and then then tries to
come back around a few weeks later to
reconcile and fix things there's
interesting story somebody actually
wrote on my community tab that's um of
the same sort of uh
vein this is women right like this is
women they will they will tell you that
they are in love with you they want to
be with you forever and ever and if
something doesn't go their way um they
can just act out right um and this is
one of the ways in which that they will
act out from time to time um the whole
she's not yours it's just your turn yeah
I mean is there truth to that yeah
sounds kind of harsh and cold like I
know that it rubs some people the wrong
way but yeah I mean if you're you know
you could say look I'm in a monogamous
relationship with my girlfriend wife
fiance whatever it happens to be right
now but the fact Still Remains that if
she's not a virgin or she didn't give
you her best see what I'm saying she she
shared her body with other men that's
that's not monogamy as is divined in the
animal kingdom that's bouncing from one
dude to another dude to another dude and
that could be three five 20 50
500 the thing is is that the more times
women get involved with different guys
it's
like it's very difficult to put it any
other way than it's like a piece of her
sort of dies and sort of like leaves on
you know as you go with that and there's
all kinds of
like scientific research that a lot of
guys that have been like block pilled
and they're more nihilistic have come up
with which I may or may not talking
about you know in a future video but
when you go down the rabbit hole
of the notion of women sharing
themselves over and over and over again
with different guys the discuss level
goes up and up and up you know as that
number goes up and up and up for you
know for some people it's like an
absolute deal breaker has has to be zero
for other guys it's like it has to be
low I can't expect zero today it's it's
impossible to expect zero women you know
women like that are very difficult to
find or they don't exist and then right
now there's people screeching right away
and about to write in comments IR Rich
what about men and women in sh I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clip's
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out